Another thing I I struggle with the the
way I came back to to to Christ, not
just the fact that I was low in my life,
is I listen to a lot of like uh atheist
debating
Christian scientists. Now, some of the
things that I struggle with is when
there's no answer in the Bible and it
doesn't clear my logical hurdle. like
>> like what
>> I I battle with like dinosaurs and I
battle with the thought of like it's
like it's not that they weren't
mentioned in the Bible. It's like
>> what would be the purpose of having this
process of I don't know a hundred
million years of dinosaurs that come
just to become extinct by the time God
decides to create the human race.
>> Who told you that's what the Bible
teaches?
>> It doesn't. I'm I'm saying that's what
science tells us. about dinosaurs and
and and and then it's like there's no
answer to it in the Bible and I can't
square the logic with scripture.
>> There is an answer to the Bible,
brother. But your Bible is short. You
have a short canon.
>> No, it's I I I I my cannon is not 66
books. Uh Sam, I have an orthodox Bible.
>> Okay, then the answer was right there,
brother. Here it is. Wisdom of Solomon
chapter 112 11216.
Do not count death court death by the
air of your life or bring on destruction
by the works of your hands because God
did not make death. So how could God
have caused animals and others to die
when it says he did not make death? Now
watch here.
Right. Watch here.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Watch here.
He and he does not delight in
destruction of the living. For he
created all things. Sorry, got to charge
my computer. He created all things.
stand my computer. I'm going to be here
all day. One second. Okay. Sorry,
brother. My computer's about to die. He
created all things
>> that so that they might exist right
here. All things. Some things
>> or all things?
>> All things.
>> So, he didn't create anything to die.
Meaning sentient life or soloulish life.
Animals are said to have souls. Genesis
21:19. Birds, right? He did not create
them to die. He does not delight in
destruction of the living for all things
so that they might exist. The generating
forces of the world are wholesome. There
is no destructive poison in them. And
the demin had is not on earth for
righteous and mortal. He just told you
he didn't create the world with any
destructive elements, poisonous elements
without death.
But then why did death come in? But the
ungodly by their words and deed summon
and death considering him a friend, they
pined away and made a covenant with him
because they are fit to belong to his
company. So the Bible told you he didn't
create dinosaurs to die or animals to
die. Nor did he create dinosaurs to harm
humans? How do I know?
Let me go through scripture. Now I'm
going to give you scripture for this.
Right?
>> Okay.
>> How do I know that if I follow Bible
straight history and not myth
mythologize it like some of these
false Christians do claim to follow the
Bible and they don't? Right? How do I
know that God did not create animals to
kill animals or humans or humans to kill
animals and that he didn't create any of
them? Not even supposed to die and not
harm one another.
>> Well, we live together in the garden
before.
>> Oh, yeah. Says you're not supposed to
eat each other. Exactly. Here.
>> Yeah.
>> Genesis 128:31. God blessed them. And
God said to them, "Be fruitful,
multiply, and fill the earth and subdue
it and have dominion over the fish of
the sea, over the birds of the air, and
over every living thing that moves upon
the earth. God said, "See, I've given
you every plant yielding seed that is
upon the face of all the earth, and
every tree with seed in its fruit. You
shall have them for food, and to every
beast of the earth, and to every bird of
the air, and to everything that creeps
on the earth, everything that has the
breath of life, I have given every green
plant for food." And it was so. God saw
everything that he had made. And indeed,
it was very good. And there was evening
and there was morning, sixth day. No one
ate flesh. Animals did not eat animals.
Animals did not eat humans. Humans did
not eat animals. Because what did he say
he gave the beasts and the birds? Green
plants, fruits, vegetables, vegetation.
When did God then change things and
allow animals to pray on animals and
humans and humans eat flesh? After the
flood? Here you go, brother. Black and
white. Genesis 9:17.
Why do you think they have to then
attack the stricity of the Bible, right?
dehistoricize it because if you follow
the Bible, you're going to know
evolution, macro evolution, is straight
up science fiction from the pit of hell.
And it was developed with the intent of
undermining the biblical worldview.
God blessed Noah and his sons and said
to him, "Be fruit to multiply and fill
the earth. The fear and dread of you
shall rest on every animal of the earth
and every bird of the air and everything
that creeps on the ground and all the
fish of the sea. At your hand they are
delivered." So, when did animals now
have an instinct to fear humans and
attack humans?
>> After I didn't realize that time went,
>> you see it right there?
>> Yeah.
>> So, when did humans and animals eat
flesh? Every moving thing that lives
shall be food for you. And just as I
gave you the green plants, I give you
everything. Only you shall not eat flesh
with its life, that is its blood. For
your own lifeblood, I will surely
require a reckoning. From every animal,
I will require it. And from human
beings, each one for the blood of
another, I'll require a reckoning for
human life. Now, notice when he gives
them flesh to eat after the flood.
>> Yeah.
>> But only don't eat with the blood in it.
Drain it. And then notice another thing.
Though animals will be now scared of
humans and be in opposition to humans,
it says even an animal will be held
accountable if it murders a human soul
unjustly.
For your own light blood, I'll surely
require a reckoning from every animal. I
will require it. Not only humans, even
animals, if they murder humans, meaning
they were not sent to punish humans,
right? They were not sent justly to kill
humans for their wickedness. God will
hold them accountable for taking the
life of humans.
>> Perfect.
>> Whoever sheds the blood of a human, by a
human shall that person's blood be shed.
For his own image, God made humans.
Now, what will God do when Jesus
returns? This is part of what your
question was, the millennial reign,
which we didn't finish, but okay. Isaiah
11 talking about the root of Jesse
that is descendant of King David because
Jesse is David's father. So, the stump,
the root of Jesse is the messianic king.
All right, everyone following me?
All right. What happens when he comes?
All right, here's what it happens. I'm
going to read verse six. The wolf shall
live with the lamb, and the leopard
shall lie down with the kid. The calf
and the lion will feed together. Oh, so
the wolf will not tear up a lamb. The
leopard will not kill a human child. The
lion will not tear to shreds a calf, and
a little child will lead a lion, a
leopard, and a wolf. The cow and the
bear shall graze. See, they're not going
to eat flesh. Their young shall lie down
together and the lion shall eat straw
like the ox. They're going to go back to
the way it was before the flood.
Okay, let's finish it though. The
nursing child shall play over the whole
of the ass. Now, if you take a child to
play in a viper's nest, snake will bite
the child. They'll die. Not when Christ
comes. It's going to be the way it was
before the flood, before sin entered the
world. And the wing child shall put its
hand on the adders. Then they will not
hurt or destroy on all my holy mountain.
For the earth will be full of the
knowledge of the Lord as the waters
cover the sea. Okay. When on that day
the root of Jesse when he shows up, the
rid of Jesse shall stand as a sign to
the peoples. Then they shall shall
acquire of him him and his dwelling
shall be glorious. Now that takes place
in the new heaven, new earth. How do I
know? Isaiah 65 verses 17 to 25.
But I'll just open up the entire
chapter. So the Bible had your answers,
brother. But right here we go to 17. For
I'm about to create new heavens and a
new earth. The former things shall not
be remembered or come to mind. But be
glad and rejoice forever in what I'm
creating. For I'm about to create
Jerusalem as a joy and its people as a
delight. I'll rejoice in Jerusalem and
delight in my people. No more shall the
sound of weeping be heard in it. No more
pain, no more suffering, or the cry of
distress. No more shall there be in it
an infant who lives but a few days. Or
an old person who does not live out a
lifetime. For one who dies in 100 years
will be considered a youth, and one who
falls short of 100 will be considered a
curse. Now, this is a poetic way of
saying if someone were to die at 100,
you're like, man, did they die young?
You're going to think hundred is young.
Whereas today if you live to be 100 like
wow, right?
>> Yeah.
>> They shall build houses and inhabit
them. They shall plant vineyards and eat
their fruit. They shall not build and
another inhabit. They shall not plant
and another eat. For like the days of a
tree shall the days of my people be. And
my chosen shall long enjoy the work of
their hands. Now watch. They shall not
labor in vain. So you're not going to
have people attacking you, robbing you,
stealing your property, murdering you to
get what you have. None of that. Your
children will live long. They won't be
sick. For they shall be offspring
blessed by the Lord. And the descendants
will hear. What about animals? Before
they call, I will answer. While they're
yet speaking, I will hear. The wolf and
the lamb shall feed together. So the
wolf won't feed a on a lamb. The lion
shall eat straw like an ox. The lion
won't tear. Pray anymore. And the
serpent will only eat dust. It won't
strike humans. They shall not hurt or
destroy on all my holy mountains, says
the Lord. See what the Bible taught
before the flood.
Animals did not eat animals. Animals did
not eat humans. Humans did not eat
animals. There was no flesh eating. It
happened after the flood. That means
when dinosaurs were created, they did
not harm, destroy.
They were living in perfect peace with
all creation because God created that
that animals, humans be at perfect
harmony. It's after the flood things
change. So that's the first part of the
answer to your question. Does the Bible
know about dinosaurs? Yes, because you
don't expect to find a modern term in a
pre-scientific book. We call them
dinosaurs. But if I were to ask you, if
I wanted to find a depiction of a
dinosaur, instead of looking for the
word, I need to see the depiction and
what word they would use. What do you
think the word was for dinosaurs in an
ancient pre-scientific community?
>> Uh, dragons.
>> You got it. as well as the behemoth.
Why do you think you have inscriptions
in ancient civilizations, drawings where
you see depictions of dinosaurs on walls
written and in literature dragons
because what you call dinosaur they call
dragons or in the Bible behemoth. Now
watch here. Tell me if this sounds like
an ordinary animal. Job 40:15.
Look at behemoth which I made just as I
made you. Heeds grass like an ox. Oh,
remember when he first created them?
They didn't eat flesh, did they?
All right. Its strength is in its loins
and its power in the muscles of its
bellies. It makes its tail stiff like a
cedar. You know how big a cedar tree is?
>> Yeah.
>> Let me show you.
It's saying the tail of this beast.
Okay. The height is like a cedar tree.
Let's see.
Does that res sound like an ordinary
animal?
What animal has a tail this long?
>> Yeah, just dinosaurs or dragons.
>> And that's what the behemoth The tail is
long and sturdy like a cedar tree. This
is not describing a buffalo or a
crocodile. Yeah,
>> this has got to be what we call a
dinosaur. All right. And that's why God
says you can't tame it. God has to tame
it. It strengthen its loins and its
power in the muscles of its belly. It
makes its tail stiff like a cedar. The
sinners of its size are knit together.
Its bones are like tombs of bronze. Its
limbs like bars of iron, meaning forget
it. You're hopeless against it. It is
the first of the great acts of God. Only
its maker can approach it with a sword.
See, only I can slay it. Sure sounds
like a dinosaur, huh?
>> Well, I I had I've read Job and I never
picked up on what I was was reading.
Oftentimes, it takes a a third and
fourth read for me to really like grasp
what I'm reading.
>> You're good. You're on a good journey.
Now, notice how big it is. For the
mountains yields food for it, where all
the wild animals play. Under the lotus
plants, it hides. You have dragons that
also live in the sea, right? Yeah,
>> what we call Leviathan. Anyway, in the
covert of the reeds and the marsh, the
lotus trees cover it for shade. The
willows of watties surround it. Even the
river is turbulent. It is not fright
because it's so huge. It is confident
though Jordan rushes against its mouth.
Can one take it with hooks or pierce its
nose with a snare? No. Your hooks and
snares are nothing useless.
Here is your dragon, your dinosaur, your
behemoth in the Bible.
Wow, incredible. Thank you so much.
>> Why do you think there is a concerted
effort to get you to lose confidence of
Genesis chapters 111? Because if you
believe Genesis, you cannot subscribe to
macro evolution. Let alone it is a
theory that's dying because they're not
able to provide facts as opposed to
theories and manipulation of data to
support it.
>> Yeah. there. It's trying to find any
wedge of doubt uh for anybody especially
for timelines I find.
>> So did you see you got your answer and
I'm proud of young man. Any other
questions?
>> No, that that's everything. Thank you so
much Sam. Thank you, brother.